[Music]
you've mentioned that you've kept
journals of ideas that you've had over
the course of your 20s and 30s I'm
curious to know what final idea sparked
in motion the entire writing of the
screenplay
the idea that and it's a sort of
celebration of life in many forms of it
of the life from so the funny expects of
the life the tiring expect of life and
so it is sort of a big picture about how
the life can be at the same time tiring
and funny and how life is full of
useless things but at other hand these
useless things compose the life and for
this reason the main character that at
the beginning is against his home life
at the hand
decided to write a second novel exactly
about the silly things that the years
that he lives for all the movie you've
said that you identify greatly with the
main character of the film so I'm
curious about writing that character how
much of it was drawn from inspiration in
your own life and how much of it was a
collaboration with your co-writer the
collaboration with my co-writer is very
simple we sit at lunch for for several
lunch and we speak about the movie then
I go back a tomb and I write the first
draft and I give him and he writes the
second draft so we we do a sort of
ping-pong with the bit script and the
other my point of view is very close to
the point of view of the main character
this case I noticed that I had forgotten
to ask you about the sequence with fanny
our dome which is a beautiful moment in
the movie and I'm curious if that was in
part because of your admiration for
Truffaut or how that how that came about
if that was in the script if it's
something that you decided to do during
production I work it with a fan hair
done in the previous movie she was in
another movie that I did and in that
scene in the script there was a the main
character that met an important person
in via veneto that's a glorious and
famous street in Rome of for la dolce
vita so in that case I was happy to do a
sort of image to la dolce vita and
veneered answered me that she has never
done in her life the extra but all the
actress and she said that once in life
it was nice for her to do the extra so I
thought it was a very good chance for me
to have an extra like Fanny Arden and so
I called out to them to play that scene
yeah and so she can tell us about
writing the the the opening scene with
the Japanese tourists at the Johnny
colla when when you're writing a
screenplay you you typically go for
something a little shocking tell us
about you know starting the story that
way the the first scene the idea was
very simple that the beauty is the thing
that all of us look forward life but at
the same time I don't know in which way
but there is something of dangerous in
the beauty and that can bring to the to
death and so in front of the beauty of
Rome I
Japanese tourists dice it was a very
simple idea and and then I my idea was
also to establish a soon that Roma is a
city where the sacred expect of the
first seen works that the sacred and the
profane work together very well in in
Romans why I decided to have a first
scene that that was something of a
absolutely seeker and the second scene
is exactly the opposite where all the
old examples of Italian decadence yeah
but also good dancers what tell us tell
us about a shooting that dense sequence
in the beginning what what sort of
preparations you do for that how how
difficult was it to shoot in that kind
of a party atmosphere no it was not done
I have to say that I had very good
access and they were very excited for
three nights to do that scene it was
unbelievable for me because usually the
access board after one or two hours but
I don't know why probably for the music
and for the general atmosphere they were
excited to do that scene for three
nights and so we it was very very tiring
but at the same at the same time for me
it's very funny to do a scene about
people that tense because I think yeah I
think that one of the most beautiful
things in life is to see the people that
dance well and for this reason I I go to
professional dancers and well they are
the the motif of juxtaposing the sacred
and the profane has is layered in many
different ways in which you construct
the film in terms of the contrast in
cinematography filming decadence the
musical selections the truth of the
music is exactly in the way that you
said that the music is a mix of sacred
and profane and it works for Anita it
helped me to say that Rome is a city
where all the days in all the moments
are sacred and profane stay together
very well and about cinematographer what
can I say it's a man with who I've done
five movies and so now we we work
without speaking each other that's the
best condition for me to avoid to speak
with with the home all the people and so
they will think to have a same person in
your crew is that you can avoid to speak
too much because during everybody knows
that during the movie you have to speak
a lot so if you can have an actor and
the cinematographer that you know very
well you can you can communicate just
looking each other